the history of German American trade
relations goes back to the late 17th
century Germans began emigrating to what
would later become the United States in
the hope of a more prosperous future in
1683 they founded Germantown today a
suburb of Philadelphia they largely
worked in brewing publishing and banking
in 1785 the then newly born United
States signed a treaty of amity and
commerce with the kingdom of prussia it
oversaw the customs free export of
american tobacco rice and whale oil and
from prussia linen porcelain and iron
increasing unemployment coupled with
famines and political upheavals prompted
a second wave of German immigration
across the Atlantic providing a huge
fresh pool of labor for American farms
and factories they helped boost the
economy of their new home by 1870 one in
seven Americans had German roots an
American industry boomed German
immigrants were responsible for a number
of its future best-selling exports
Levi's Strauss's new business in San
Francisco marked the birth of a street
clothing Empire levi's jeans in the very
same year Heinrich stein vague founded
the piano making company that would
become the world-famous Steinway & Sons
the first part of the 20th century saw
freeze and relations and trade between
the two nations due to the First World
War the later global financial crisis
saw the u.s. stop its loans to Europe in
1934 Nazi Germany terminated a trade
agreement with the US after the Second
World War when West Berlin was blockaded
by the Soviets the city survived thanks
to an american-led airlift and in the
1950s loans and raw materials from the
US helped West Germany undergo its
economic miracle then bilateral trade
really took off again in 1971 McDonald's
opened its first branch in West Germany
in Munich and in 1992 BMW opened its
first factory in the US the partnership
between reunified Germany and the u.s.
continued to intensify and in 2015 the
US overtook France to become Germany's
number one trading partner